[Music]
is it true that your husband almost
missed the birth he did okay about that
because he was filming a big movie
called barely lethal with a Hailee
Steinfeld in Sam Jackson and Sam Jackson
only had a finite amount of time to film
and they said legitimately to me if he
if you go on your due date your husband
will not be allowed to fly back for the
birth so I was praying I know this
sounds horrible died that the baby came
a tiny bit earlier or tunning it later
because you want your husband there
absolutely and so I took I I didn't feel
alone I called the doctor he's like yeah
you don't want to go but just just go to
the doc go to the hospital and check it
out so I took it over because I thought
an ambulance would be very dramatic you
took an you're you're you think you
might be having a baby yeah you took an
uber car yeah water to break in your own
pants yeah like they say three minutes
away and in ambulance you don't know
right right I can rely on uber so I took
it over there uber evidence sorry kids
don't call an ambulance if there's
trouble
Oh uber he brought me all about the
labor and delivery and I was a laborer
for 20s hope you gave him five stars or
whatever oh yes I did I did
you